الخصومه في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه تخطت
اللاعبين الرئيسيين وبات كل طرف يحارب على
جبهات متعدده ليس عسكريا بالضروره تقرير
لصحيفه واشنطن بوست كشف ان اوكرانيا تقوم
بتعزيز الدفاعاتها على حدودها مع
بيلاروسيا عبر زرعها الاف الالغام للدقه
اكثر اوكرانيا زرعت اكثر من 6000 لغه مضاد
للدبابات على طول حدودها مع بيلاروسيا
وروسيا لتحصين دفاعاتها في المقابل موسكو
منشغله بالعمل على مواجهه الهجمات
الاوكرانيه المحتمله في الاسابيع المقبله
حيث يكثف الروس خطوط تحصيناتهم على الجبهه
وفي شبه جزيره القرم لمنع اختراق قوات كاف
وفق صحيفه الفرنسيه لانه اذا تمكنت
اوكرانيا من اختراق هذه الخطوط سيكون احد
العوامل الحاسمه في نجاح او فشل الهجوم
المضاد الاوكراني المعلن في الربيع